alors je précise qu'on sera en direct
jusqu'à je ne sais pas jusqu'à quel
heure mais en tous les cas à 17h30 ce
qui est prévu c'est qu'il ya la
passation de pouvoir donc messieurs
notre débat il faut qu'ils durent
jusqu'à 17h30 mais pas une minute de
plus pour qu'on puisse vivre en direct
donc cette passation et que l'on
commentera ensuite avec vous et avec
vous bien sûr qu'ils nous regardent et
donc vous restez avec nous êtes vous
satisfait de la démission d'edouard
philippe c'est la question qu'on vous
pose en ce moment sur le site du figaro
il y en a un qui garde les yeux secs
c'est une christian jacob en tout cas si
l'on en juge par ce qu'il déclarait
avant ce matin avant le communiqué et
l'annoncent le communiqué de l'elysée et
l' annonce de la démission d'edouard
philippe c'était chez sonia mabrouk sur
europe 1 il a trahi sa famille politique
il réalise en il a conduit une politique
qui qui a conduit à l'impasse que je
viens d'évoquer les résultats
économiques sont là pour en témoigner
et on ne parle que des résultats
économiques on peut parler de la
sécurité et on est dans une situation
catastrophique
on est dans une situation catastrophique
c'est ce que déclare christian jacob
êtes vous satisfait de la démission
d'edouard philippe c'est la question
qu'on vous pose sur le site du figaro qu
est ce que vous pensez du bilan du
premier ministre et vous d'accord avec
ce que dit christian jacob et vous
étienne girard est ce que vous êtes
aussi sévère que le patron des
républicains sur le bilan du désormais
nouveau maire du havre et ancien
désormais ancien premier ministre
dl bilan du maire du havre c'est le
bilan du président de république il n'y
aura pas de bilan d'edouard philippe à
proprement parler au moins en terme de
réformes politiques
il a exécuté le programme politique
voulue par emmanuel macron là dessus et
françaises seront juge en 2022 il ya
bien plein de choses à dire on peut
quand même dire que le si la situation
économique aujourd'hui n'est pas
florissante
c'est aussi peut-être surtout pas
ce qui a eu le coc vie de 19,6 on attend
un certain nombre de faillites
d'entreprises c'est aussi peut-être
surtout pour ça cela dit edouard
philippe
pendant son passage à matignon n'aura
pas marqué par des réformes particulière
la seule à laquelle il a inscrit son nom
vraiment il a souhaité inscrire son nom
c'est le passage aux 80 km heure sur la
route
bon ça restera pas à mon sens une
réforme d'ampleur en revanche il a à
forger un personnage politique il a
forgé un style politique
un style qui me semble-t-il plaît et il
servira play ou en tout cas au à
l'électorat qu'il vive c'est à dire un
électorat plutôt de centre et de droite
qui aime à la fois ce flegme et cette
forme de rigidité sur les grands
équilibres budgétaires
pas de réformes un style politique
c'est ce que vous c'est aussi votre
regard maxime d'égailler je vous pose la
question parce que vous êtes comme
etienne vous êtes à ma gauche
écoutez pas de réforme
moi je trouve qu'il a eu un peu de
mérite edouard philippe il a finalement
géré dourdan et cette confusion du
maquereau nisme il a eu bien souvent il
a fait preuve de cohérence
c'est un homme de droite qui a mis en
place une politique de droite et ça je
ne peux pas lui en vouloir
et si vous voulez moi je donc je
considère qu'il a fait son job il est
qu'il a été il était populaire alors je
pense que sa popularité est le miroir de
la popularité de macron mai mais il a
exercé son rôle de premier ministre est
en réalité le sujet qui est posé
aujourd'hui aux dents pour le
gouvernement et pour emmanuel macron
c'est une recherche de légitimité parce
que healy finalement leur légitimité
épuisé et ce qui est paradoxal avec au
départ de leur clip c'était c'est
peut-être que c'est le seul acteur de la
macro ni dont la légitimité était encore
un peu voyante
j'ai envie de dire qu'il fallait tout
changer parce qu'il ya plus de
légitimité parlementaire il ya plus de
légitimité présidentielle
le peu de légitimité qui restait était
celle d'edouard
libre parce que et il a gouverné à
droite sur un problème de droite en
étant un homme de droite
je salue les inviter les internautes
vous nous rejoignez je salue notamment
nathan fidèles internautes nicole
également qui est là avec nous quasiment
tous les soirs bonsoir nicole est
également cet internaute anonyme qui
nous dit l air crient à la trahison
d'edouard philippe mais oublie de dire
que castex fait exactement de même alors
c'est exactement ce qu'a dit d'ailleurs
christian jacob
cet après midi en réaction à la
nomination du maire de prades comme
nouveau premier ministre on y reviendra
en deuxième partie un homme de droite
qui a mené une politique de droite
puisque vous êtes le théoricien du
mouvement dextrogyre guillaume bernard
est ce que c'est l'analyse que vous
faites sur le bilan des leurs philippe
moi il me semble qu'il faut quand même
toujours faire la différence entre ce
qui est à droite sur l'échiquier
politique et ce qui est véritablement de
droite
lorsque je parle du mouvement
d'explosifs j'ai dit que c'est ce qui
est de droite qui est en train de
regagner du terrain à la fois électorale
et idéologiques et pas simplement ceux
qui à un moment donné se retrouve sur la
droite du spectre politique alors que
edouard philippe soit sur la droite du
spectre politique c'est parfaitement
exact qu'ils soient nécessairement de
droite ça j'ai quand même plus de doute
il me semble quand même que le bilan du
gouvernement lors philippe c'est quand
même un bilan qui gérait va ont plutôt
ressemblé à un dépôt de bilan
les gilet jaune les grèves sur la
question de la réforme des retraites un
taux d'abstention record aux élections
municipales
j'en conviens dans des circonstances
particulières mais enfin tout de même
et puis des commandes hier des mesures
qui ou des noms mesure qui disent ne
serait ce que symboliquement la loi
bioéthique où la sphère de vincent
lambert
il me semble tout de même que sur
l'ensemble de ces questions par une
forme de libéralisme par une forme de
progressisme non edouard philippe ne se
situe pas je dirais dans l'ue
la famille politique de droite il est à
droite et objectivement dans l'ue
d'après partie de cette grande coalition
macro nien macron a réussi en 2017 à et
bien siphonner le parti socialiste il
est en train avec edouard philippe et
jean castex de finir de diviser les
républicains c'est de bonne guerre c'est
le jeu politicien mais enfin tout de
même on n'est pas à la hauteur des
événements
je vous rappelle quand même que on vous
n'êtes à la veille d'une crise
économique et sociale gravissime qu'il y
a eu énormément déjà deux personnes qui
ont été mises au chômage et que le taux
d'endettement de la france atteint des
ddd niveau 2 qui n'avait jamais été
atteint jusqu'à présent donc par
conséquent je crois que le maire de le
maire du havre se met à l'abri parce que
si les français considèrent qu'il a
peut-être bien géré ce n'est pas mon
avis mais qu'il a peut-être bien géré la
crise sanitaire
je crois que ceux qui vont être au
gouvernement demain on peut les plaindre
vont avoir une situation économique et
sociale extrêmement graves à gérer et
donc notre ami ou votre ami edouard
philippe
tu crois qu'il a d'une certaine manière
raison de ne pas continuer je dirais à
être gouvernement alors
je ne sais pas qui vous disiez votre ami
edouard philippe peut-être au 59 % des
français qui souhaitaient et qu'il reste
le premier ministre jean daniel lévy on
entend des des avis qui sont très
sévères sur ce plateau en revanche on a
celui de babineau qui nous dit j'aime la
sobriété de la cohérence d'edouard
philippe je comprends sa popularité il a
fait son temps pourquoi les français
tenait de temps maintien d'edouard
philippe à matignon déjà on peut
effectivement indiqué que c'est pas
forcément une chose absolument
indépassable que dans d'autres
circonstances par exemple si on prend
les élections municipales de 2014
les français n'étaient pas pour le
maintien à l'époque de jean marc ayrault
à matignon donc il peut y avoir des
défaites électorales avec des
traductions de pino qui peuvent être
relativement différente
on peut également rappeler que on
critique parfois les responsables
politiques parce qu'ils sont censés
gouverner avec les sondages on voit que
la emmanuel macron sonné la franchise
ixina affranchis parce qu'il va contre
une opinion majoritaire il va même entre
l'opinion majoritaire de son corps
politique parce que près de huit
électeurs sur dix du premier tour
d'emmanuel macro comme sept électeurs
sur dix de françois fillon déclarait
qu'il fallait conserver edouard philippe
à matignon alors pourquoi disent-ils ça
ben parce que parfois c'est un peu le
miroir inversé de ce qu'est le président
de la république et que lorsque on parle
d' edouard philippe
on parle de ce que n'est pas emmanuel
macron et dans le cadre de sa gestion de
la crise par exemple de la manière dont
il a plus abordés donc il a vu abordées
les thématiques un malaise il a pu
s'exprimer
aux yeux des français il a donné le
sentiment d'être dans une forme de
clarté dans une forme d'explication de
pédagogie même si je n'adore pas
forcément ce terme là et de prendre
systématiquement le temps de pouvoir
dire ce que pourrait faire le
gouvernement ce qu'il ne pouvait pas
faire de ne pas être seule à prendre la
parole et de la déléguée à différents
acteurs notamment à olivier viron mais
pas que et donc d'avoir cette forme
d'exercice qui est un exercice qui
n'apparaissait pas comme étant
uniquement descendants uniquement
condescendant mais qui a été dans une
forme de travail de partage des
informations de ce qui était atteignable
et de ce qui n'était pas atteignable
le fait que contrairement au président
de la république il ne donnait pas le
sentiment d'être donneur de leçons le
fait que contrairement au président de
l'apli qui ne donnait pas de sentiment
d'ailleurs de ne donner que des
mauvaises nouvelles mais également de
proposer des perspectives a globalement
rassuré si ce n'est une grande majorité
de français en tout cas on l'a vu plus
d'un français sur deux au cours de la
dernière période et c'était valable
notamment juste avant l'élection
municipale et ce week end
approuvez-vous la démission d'edouard
philippe c'est la question qu'on vous
pose sur le site du figaro est pour
l'instant vous êtes une large majorité à
répondre non à cette question qui vous
est posée depuis ce matin jean daniel
lévy je reviens vers vous est ce que la
mission que emmanuel macron confié à
partir de ce soir edouard philippe
à savoir mener une espèce de
confédération des partis macro nist pour
2022 à la fois rm est également les
dissidences ça peut marcher pas ça peut
marcher si free mobile
ça peut marcher si voir philippe est
prêt à jouer complètement d'où une des
craintes on le sait de la part du
président a répliqué c'est de voir
émerger une personne qui aurait une cote
d'opinion suffisamment forte pour
pouvoir éventuellement le concurrencer
dans le cadre de la prochaine
présidentielle
et il n'a pas forcément entièrement tort
de se méfier des doigts fripés jeudi par
le département met déjà en terme
d'opinion et quand on compare la
structure d'opinion d'emmanuel macron et
de celle d'edouard philippe on peut voir
que global plus confiance à l'égard d'
edouard philippe est relativement élevée
de la part des sympathisants la
république en marche à peu près au même
niveau que celle des manières macron
mais qu'il ya un point qui les
singularise c'est qu'il a une très forte
un très fort niveau de confiance de la
part des sympathisants de droite qui ne
lui en veulent pas visiblement d'avoir
accepté la mission confiée par emmanuel
macron donc il ya aujourd'hui un espace
politique à droite qui est inoccupée et
on le voit bien d'ailleurs à travers les
intentions de vote qui seront réalisés à
l'heure actuelle quels que soient les
têtes de listes qui sont testés on peut
voir qu'ils dépassent rarement les 12 à
15 % et qui fait que nous avons à
l'heure actuelle un candidat potentiel
qui a une légitimité d'opinion et qui
peut être à certains égards peut
rappeler françois fillon qui est sorti
je vous le rappel de matignon auxerre
après cinq ans avec une cote de
confiance qui a été extrêmement élevé et
qui lui a permis en tout cas de pouvoir
gagner la primaire interne de la droite
et du centre en 2016 une autre réaction
qui est donnée par nos internautes
puisqu'on parle de cet espace de la
droite et du centre
c'est nathan qui est ironique à l'égard
de françois bayrou pauvre bayrou lui
aussi a été réélu dans les pyrénées
atlantiques et une fois de plus on n'a
pas songé à lui comment vous interprétez
d'ailleurs le fait que par exemple y ait
pas eu ce recours au centre étienne
girard très très simplement il n'y a pas
de recours à françois bayrou parce que
françois bayrou est mis en examen dans
une affaire d'emploi possiblement
fictifs au parlement européen ce qui le
disqualifie pour devenir premier
ministre et pas une disqualification
juridique puisque rien n'empêcherait
juridiquement de le choisir
mais c'est une disqualification
politique c'est-à-dire qu'ils emmanuel
macron n'a pas envie de prendre le
risque d'avoir un premier ministre
fragilisé par ce type d'affaires
ensuite le centre c'est encore
plus simple c'est que si ton si si on
retire françois bayrou il n'y a pas de
figure aujourd'hui nationale qui incarne
le centre et qui serait politiquement
légitime à devenir premier ministre
c'est tout simplement pour ça que on
n'aura pas d'ici à la fin du quinquennat
de grands centriste à matinée il y à un
débat actuellement sur le chat vous vous
débattez sur justement la place du
premier ministre dans le casting
exécutif si je puis m'exprimer ainsi
cet internaute qui est anonyme également
ce qu'on regrette pas ce qu'il dit une
chose intéressante
la suppression du septennat a transformé
le président en une sorte d'empereur
pour cinq ans babineau nous dit
également sur estime tout de même
l'importance du rôle du premier ministre
sur la cinquième ce sont des exécutants
maxime d'égailler vous disiez que le
bilan était quasiment inexistant pour
edouard philippe c'est votre point de
vue c'est votre opinion mais est-ce que
c'est pas justement à supposer que ce
soit vrai dû à ça à cette disposition
près à disposition du pouvoir exécutif
mais j'espère que indique au val excusez
moi j'ai pas dis que j'ai pas dit que le
bilan des morts était faible
j'ai dit qu'il était de droite alors je
trouve ça va partir en violant de
considérer que ce qui est de droite est
faible
ceci étant dit je pourrai répondre à
votre question pour pour répondre à la
question je pense que le seul à la
nomination de jean castex
d'ailleurs comme le départ d'edouard
philippe et le retour de
l'hyperprésidence de damon et le
maquereau c'est à dire qu' il ne veut
pas gouverner avec un premier bout fort
il veut pas donc le gouverner avec un
parlement dont dire est fort et il peut
pas gouverner que les français mais on
est quand même dans une verte
verticalité absolue et donc le poste du
poste de premier ministre
il aurait pu considérer que au delà des
heures de pose des premiers ce même le
gouvernement
il aurait pu considérer qu'il fallait
renforcer la légitimité politique dudit
aider des gens qui l'entourent je vous
rappelle après la crise de 2008
de mémoire le gouvernement fillon est
transformée il ya le retour d'alain
juppé
donc on fait venir des poids lourds
autour de françois fillon je pense d'une
part pour potentiellement le relativiser
et surtout parce que la période de crise
n'était cité on va dire le muscler un
peu l'équipe en désignant jean castex
c'est pas du tout ça qui est fait c'est
d'une certaine manière un nouveau cas
effectivement un collaborateur qui a pas
de légitimité politique qui est installé
à la tête de matignon et on peut
considérer qu'une fois de plus c'est une
volonté pour emmanuel macron non pas
d'être dans des logiques de coalition
mais d'être dans une vision assez
absolue du pouvoir et là dessus j'ai
tendance à dire qu'on va voir comment
sera le reste du gouvernement enfin jean
castex et le chef du comex soit vous
avez empiéter sur la deuxième partie
vous avez ajusta connaissez la note
juste à côté de deux mois les membres
des personnels qui travaillent donc à
matignon qui attendent la passation donc
de pouvoir l'arrivée de jean castex et
le départ d'edouard philippe alors
question celle quand vous posez sur le
site du figaro êtes vous satisfait de la
démission d'edouard philippe vous êtes
une large majorité à répondre non vous
pouvez continuer à voter 73% pour
l'instant vous vous dites non il ya une
autre question qu'on vous pose mais
cette fois ci sur twitter c'est si vous
approuvez bien le choix de son
successeur
approuvez-vous le choix de jean castex
comme premier ministre alors en temps on
a compris que ce n'était pas la tasse de
thé de maxi